hey everybody welcome to this episode of
fat man i'm batman i am mark barnard and
and i am all by myself I am as one might
say solo ah why is that because we're
gonna talk about solo so come on back
that men on Batman hey so it's me by
myself and our old standby home scum and
villainy cantina and Kev is up doing keV
stuff in Vancouver if you've been
following his social media feeds you
know that that means he's shooting an
episode of flash and there's flashes all
over the place and plastic man's all
over the place and it's all it's all
masks and fun and rubber
'inna in Vancouver which is pretty much
what you assume Vancouver is anyway
right masks and rubber and fun but yes
last night during the or whenever that
was ago I don't know where this is going
to drop but in recent past during the
Superbowl
there was a teaser for solo a Star Wars
movie Star Wars story and then the
following day you got the full our first
like minute 45 to a minute look at the
latest Star Wars movie two minutes is
not a lot to go on but first reactions I
kind of really want to Lando a Star Wars
story more than I want solo with Star
Wars movie and that's only because I
loved on a Glover and only because I
love Lando Calrissian but also this
trailer while kind of cool and
definitely kind of Moody and feel Star
Wars II in the same way the rogue one
felt like Star Wars I don't get much of
a read from Alden Ehrenreich the guy
they plucked from not at all obscurity
to play Han Solo because he's met in the
trailer much immigrant nobody's in the
trailer that much aside from you know an
awesome coat that Lando Calrissian wears
which may or may not be made of like
Sarlacc innards or wookie fur or
whatever whatever you think it is is
what it is but you know you get a couple
of lines in a couple of looks from that
guy and and I gotta say like not quite
feeling it but maybe he has to maybe
that kind of laconic Leanback rogue
scoundrel is a lived-in feel it's like
the jeans that you've worn for like 10
years and they feel just right
maybe at this point found solo yeah I
mean we're in the cantina so shit's
gonna happen
han Solo hasn't worn in his persona just
yet maybe he's still a little bit too
shiny maybe his hairs a little too
bouncy I don't know it it goes a bunch
of different ways but this feels like a
heist movie to the point where you get
woody house and showing up saying hey
I'm putting together a crew to do a job
that sounds like it's Ocean's eleven but
in space and maybe Lunda will have to
steal somebody's uh I don't know
virginity in order to make himself a
ship who can tell I don't know but again
here for the Lando movie a little bit
more than me over the Han Solo movie I'm
also a little bit sleepy of every female
character in the Star Wars universe
being a Caucasian brunette with a
British accent I'm not counting Tandy
Newton who is a black brunette with a
British accent but I mean hey they shook
it up just a little bit so I'll take it
you see like glimpses and of stuff like
hey he's got the dice on that thing
which I guess the dice didn't come with
the Falcon you see Maz Kanata and so
maybe Han Solo is gonna [ __ ] Maz Kanata
in this movie all things are possible
you know we have a galaxy of stories to
choose from although it's funny like
looking at this trailer one doesn't see
the sense of comedy that that I'm in
Lord where apparently fired for
injecting into their Star Wars movie
maybe part of Ron Howard's mission was
to iron out all of the wrinkles of fun
that might have been in there because
this doesn't look like it's fun really
and it's it's weird because a movie like
this you feel you feel this in inertia
this drag towards lightness or you sort
of feel like I listen this is before the
[ __ ] we're weird this is you know Han
Solo bouncing out of the Academy this is
like Top Gun but in Star Wars it kind of
felt like it should be a little less
stand Torian and a little bit more
bouncy in a way but it's a Star Wars
movie in Star Wars movies you know say
what you want
they are very rarely bouncy there are a
lot of things she's not bouncy Thor
apparently can be bouncy you know and
not that you'd want the kind of Ragnarok
feel from a Star Wars movie but maybe
there's a way to split the difference of
this field
a little bit more Ocean's eleven and a
little bit less rogue two but hey again
this was two minutes we got to look at
and I will I will take a Star Wars movie
that gives me you know shiny immaculate
Millennium Falcon that apparently uses
its bumpers to fling Tie Fighters in to
asteroids and maybe that was the Kessel
run feels like it was probably the
Kessel run right I mean it would have to
be the Kessel run why do you not do that
why do not show us this thing it's not
gonna be a Kessel run come on of course
it's the Kessel run yeah I mean I'm I'm
holding out hope I always hold out hope
for these sorts of things it is not the
most excited that I've ever been after
looking at it at a teaser but I also I'm
totally cognizant of the fact that it's
just a teaser it is just there to get us
a little giddy for this thing to show us
the thing that we were wondering why
they didn't show us for a movie that's
coming on in three months you know and
hey it's - it's a Star Wars movie and
good bad indifferent there is always
room in my heart in first Star Wars
movie
so yeah I'm eagerly anticipating the
next trailers I'm easily anticipating
getting to see a little bit more of what
the story shape feels like and if it
does have a sense of humor to it or if
it is just you know sort of grim
proceeding our way through a heist
without so much as a smile unless that
smile comes from Lando Calrissian who
looks like he's going to sleep with
every person on that screen including a
Wookiee and I would not put it past him
because he's Donald [ __ ] Glover so he
can do that [ __ ]
so yeah just eager for more excited for
more it whet the appetite but it didn't
satisfy it's not supposed to it's a
teaser it's an appetizer it's a it's a
pair of teef which is probably boozy all
right no it's a French word I'm not sure
so yeah Hey that is that is the way I
feel about the solo when Kevin's back in
the world or these back in the country
I'm sure we'll have more to say about
solo things but for now this is me doing
solo solo Markman Arden for famine I'm
Batman here at scum and villainy Cantina
so yeah come on back we are we're gonna
spool it back up again once keV was back
and we're gonna give you wall to wall
famine on Batman until your eyes bleed
and you
Hertz and other [ __ ] happens to other
body parts so yeah mark barnard n' come
back next time same fat time same
channel SModcast calm or youtube.com /
Kevin Smith
[Music]
you